see ya it was actually like super
excitement coming to like a massive
studio from being a fan of MOBAs and
eSports have been all since I was young
I've loved that kind of atmosphere and
coming into the SL then and it being so
professional and so like intense it was
really really awesome and yeah I had so
much fun
Maria beat em beat em game soon there'll
be a lot of players there had a lot of
public to all community members or were
youtubers to studios they're set apart
with both teams and got to be the
captain of one of the TV team Germanicus
the best about that have been typically
no suddenly very professionally done
ESL hosting the event was superb it
presented to everyone the stream went
really really well with the team we we
spell ourselves help you kind of in a
semi-circle in the studio as we had five
on each side and sort of dedicated to
kind of sub commanders from my team at
getting dark and paulus and I'd kind of
give them my overall strategy which was
quite basic to win let's see if they
could make up for it we're hearing there
you go again we're gonna stick with line
in heart and playing agony duck and it's
fine follow them so they're gonna be
into the blue team for Team Germanicus
now see if they can get
well the main idea was to sort of probe
and possible push if we found out that
there they had a tops two guys there and
then just react so what's going on here
at top Baron has got his legionaries and
what he's sorry his principal he's put
them into an attack that pseudo so
they're not gonna take much damage from
from range attack slowly walk forward
here but dr. Baron have to make a
decision what they want to do here
because they don't have any missiles of
their own so they can be carried quite
heavily on the top verse so they were
staying back and just watching us ready
to come in in case any snuck through on
either the left or right flanks we have
hot gates and once you have a mountain
we were pushing troops up there to see
which of those who were gonna hold or
which one we're gonna losers nobody's
bows and we can pull back and hold in
the centre when I saw both of those
sides breaking up and making their moves
that's when we pushed up in the middle
so I strive came with me and yeah we
pushed on through they must have a lot
of troops help back here Leonidas I
think they've gone full of defensive
they realize they've got positional
advantage the hood gates pushing through
you can see the Vipond down the side
he's pulling out the support he's got
archers covering off that cavalry can do
nothing for mechanize the last unit he's
got left Hugo's on the roundup
corralling them in a lion are taking a
big bit of damage so yeah so how do we
care you know for health units and its
artillery comes in you know fire effects
burning on them you know it's doing a
lot of damage look at someone morale but
you know killing him producing my my
units Eisenhart it's not more like just
loses about half of the
that was his compilers caught standing
still when I really needed keep moving
and it's one of those moments worth
waiting for everyone else to kind of
push him from the flanks I was holding
in the middle she'll just kept pushing a
little bit further the hill was lost so
we're gonna stay there a fight and die
just go through the gap that they've
left and go behind and hope that they'll
change the sneaking up actually we're on
the top is that Duke this Duke actually
called so yeah sure you've survived and
somehow becoming on the top tip the guy
again doc he's fantastic when he said it
says a movement range and how he moves
his trips is brilliant we knew that was
coming behind this person so we had
literally nothing we could do about that
because we need to spend there as the
well base Mecca it's on I managed to
slip away with his cavalry so he was
harassing us from the flanks a little
bit I would just try to get in there cuz
they had some they had some heavy a
between arrows like what a buddy maybe I
need to get him then outrun do some
damage holding back a lot of troops
still alive getting into odds cap radius
is gonna start causing problems so you
seek to play a numbers still very very
close dancer actually completely troops
difference between the two teams so this
is still a very tight fight it came
apart very quickly that we're starting
to lose a base and the pressure from the
enemy was getting quite intense so we
had to abandon and push on the right
flank bring these down and try and
support if we could any defense this guy
this is a very very tight fight that's
for sure
good defensive work from Leonidas but
the question is have they got enough and
Jesse comes here using his hog weights
the best effect and he's just you say
who's gonna get surrounded just playing
with hog whites and could be all kind of
collapse in the center base and there
were still a few of the other teams
units just wandering round the outside
they weren't that strong but they were
coming back in and we had again we had
all these exposed Archer and skirmishers
along the front and my unit I just
slammed I think it's Jesse Cox you know
- trying to take out some of his
infantry and terminators as well and I
was just trying to as much damage today
taking some friends ourselves as widgets
gonna pin these go down you know
sheelane is as well cuz you're gonna
kill them Cara get it round the back
there completely Riley down five hundred
games get a little bit of team to have a
gin Snickers teeth that's a big thing in
this thing that is a huge problem but
you could today they pushed forward and
took advantage of every single mistake I
made that was basically it
they took everything they could possibly
take I capitalized on it really really
really well and just kept the aggression
on if they to stop for even a minute we
would have our time to reform and we
might have been able to turn around but
they didn't make up the pressure at
constantly and they just got again there
is just no holds barred you're going to
die and we're gonna take you down yeah
we just tried as best we could to hold
on to the base as long as you feel
unfortunately a bit didn't pay off so it
was really important so it's a break you
just as soon as we finally managed to
push through them the rest of the troops
just kind of fell away and we ought to
get up get a victory there she lost a
battle on the top but they have full
control in the middle and that's really
where they did the damage yeah
/ can you take connecting to it at all
and then deciding to to walk back when
they realize they're actually deciding
okay
you